اهلا بكم هذه بانوراما من العربيه يقدمها
لكم صهيب شراير ونتابع فيها
لماذا انقسم الجمهوريون على كيفين مكارثي
رئيس المجلس النواب رغم دعم ترامب له
ولماذا اثار الانقسام سخريه الديمقراطيين
وغضب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
اتفقوا عليه منذ اكثر من 80 عاما واختلفوا
عليه الان كتاب في ظلال القران لسيد قطب
يثير القزامات حاده في صفوف جماعه الاخوان
لماذا اثار كتاب قديم كل هذا الجبل
ومع بدايه عام جديد كيف نطمئن على صحتنا
النفسيه وكيف نحافظ عليها وما هي علامات
المرض النفسي وكيف يمكن تجنبه
لليوم الثالث ارجع مجلس النواب الامريكي
جلسه انتخاب رئيس له بعد عده جولات اقتراع
جديده فاشلت خلالها الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في
حشد الاصوات اللازمه الانتخابي مرشحها
كيفما كارثي رئيسا مكان في النائب على
ولايه كاليفورنيا لم يتمكن في اقناع حوالي
20 نائبا جمهوريه من زملائه من مؤيد
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بانتخابه
خالفا لنانسي اذ ان هؤلاء ضلوا على رايهم
بانه معتدل اكثر مما ينبغي ان نجد انه
خلال جولات التصويت السته لم يتمكن مكارثي
من تجاوز عتبه المئتين وثلاثه الاصوات
ويتطلب انتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب ثالث اهم
شخصيه في السياسه الامريكيه بعد الرئيس
غالبيه من
ومن المفترض اي واصله النواب التصويت حتى
انتخاب رئيس المجلسهم وهذا الامر يمكن ان
يستغرق ساعات كما يمكن ان يستغرق اس فمثلا
في عام
1859 لم يتفق اعضائه الكونغرس على رئيس
الا بعد شهرين
ومئه وثلاث 133 جوله التصوير
الجديد
رئيس مجلس النواب
انقسام الجمهوري
المتمرضون للجمهوريون يمثلون اليوم تهديدا
اكبر بكثير من حزب من الفريق اليسري الذي
كان يمثل التهديدا للديمقراطيين
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب اكد دعمه
الكبير لمقافي قال اعتقد انها لعبه خطيره
وانا اؤيد مقاسي وانجاز الصفقه وارفض
استمرار الوضع الحالي
نناقش الموضوع من جده مع الباحث في
العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور بندر الدوشي ومن
هيوستن مع احمد الحنطي الباحث في شان
الامريكي مرحبا بكما ضيفيه الكريمين ضيفه
من هيوستن ابدا معك استاذ احمد لماذا يرفض
العشرون نائبا جمهوريا التصويت لصالح كيفن
مكارثي الجمهوري ليصبح رئيسا لمجلس النواب
السلام عليكم
ليست اول مره يمارسون هذا الامر
فعلوها في 2015 يعني في اكثر من مناسبه
ولكن لما تغير اليوم هو الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه صغيره جدا بالتالي لا يمكن
انتخاب متحدث بدون اصواتهم فهذا ما يعني
ما وضع العقده في المنشار لكنها ليست اول
مره يفعل ذلك نعم طيب همم ليست اول مره
ضيفي من جد الدكتور بندر الدوشي ليست اول
مره ولكن هذه المره يعني كان هناك تشجيع
من الرئيس دونالد ترامب على انهاء ما وصفه
بهذه اللعبه الجاريه وطبعا همم المساله
متعلقه بالاغلبيه التي حصل عليها
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب وبالتالي
سيزيحون نانسي فلوس
من رئاسه هذا المسجد فلماذا الاعتراف
انا اعتقد الحزب الجمهوري يعني بعام 2016
بعد انتخاب الرئيس الامريكي دون الكرام
الرئيس السابق حاليا
[موسيقى]
المؤسسات العميقه والممثلات الرسميه
المستنقاع ولا
الطبقه السياسيه
لا تقدم المصلحه السياسيه وبالتالي هذا
الفصيل همم اصبح ينمو بشكل كبير وهو موالي
للرئيس الامريكي دون ترامب واا بالتالي
هناك عتب على بانه همم جمهوري العيون
الديمقراطيه ونعرف انه عام 2007 النواب
الامريكي وهذه الفتره الثانيه الذي فيها
وبالتالي هو شخصيه همم مثيره للجدل ايضا
من الجانب الديمقراطيه الجمهوريون ال- ال-
يعتبرونه
الشخصيه همم لم تحمي ترامب من لجنه سته
يناير همم اذان الترام في اقتحام الكونجرس
بينما الديمقراطين يعتقدون ان مسافه هو
همم شخصيه متشدده دعم ترامب في لجنه
البيانات همم لم يمسح طيب او مشاركين في
اللجنه وبالتالي هو اصبح شخصيه مثيره
للجدل النظر لمحاولته ساكن عصا من المنتصر
طيب همم سيد احمد الحنفي كما استمعت يعني
همم هذه المجموعه من النواب الجمهوريين
يتهمون كما قال ضيفي من جده كذا بانه
جمهوري
بعيون ديمقراطيه بمعنى انه همم يعني معتدل
اكثر من اللازم كي يكون جمهوريه ربما همم
الى ما يستندون في هذا ما هي اوجه
الاعتدال التي يرونها في همم كيفن كارت
تجعلهم يعطلون التصويت لست جولات على
الاقل
الحقيقه انك مهكرتي ليس معتدل كلمه كارثي
يعني محافظ هو كقائد سياسي قائد ضعيف ليس
قوي لذلك لم يتمكن من جمع الاصوات ولكن
المشكله مع الفريدون كوكيز مع هذه
المجموعه المعارضه للتصويت لصالح مكارثي
ليست في شخص مكارثي هم فئه تعيش على
الاثاره تعيش على الاعتراض تعيش على
المعارضه فقط هم يريدون ان يعارضون ولا
يقدمون اي حلول يعني لو راينا لو نظرنا
الى قائمه المطالبه التي قدمهم قدموا
قائمه مطالب يعني صعبه جدا ومع ذلك لم
يتعهدوا بالتصويت اذا تم الموافقه عليه
يعني هذه المطالب قد تدفع بعضنا الى
التصويت لصالح مكارثي بالتالي وهم يريدون
فقط يريدون المعارضه والتعطيل بدون اي
اجندات سياسيه او اهداف فعليه هذا ما
يعيشون عليها وهذا ما يريدونه نعم الدكتور
بندر تسمعني
طيب دكتور بعد
التواصل معك ريس ما يصلح زملاء الصوت
قليلا مع الدكتور بندر طيب استاذ احمد
داني اسالك كذلك على
مساله تحذير ترامب من اللعبه الخطيره هو
وجه كلامه بشكل مباشر لهذه المجموعه 20
نائب جمهوري بالذات وقال بانهم يلعبون
لعبه خطيره ودعاهم لانهائها فورا يعني
ماذا يقصد بموضوع اللعبه الخطيره وهم نواب
جمهوريون وهم يعني من المؤيدين لضلال
ترامب من الفصيل او من الجناح المؤيد
لدراهم في الحزب الجمهوري فماذا يقصد
باللعبه الخطيره
ما يشير اليه الرئيس ترامب وما اشر اليه
كثير من الجمهوريين انه ما هو المخرج من
هذه الازمه اذا رفض الفريدان كوكيز رفضت
هذه المجموعه مكونه من 20 نائب اي شيء اذا
سيكون البديل اما اللجوء الى تغيير قواعد
التصويت بحيث ان يكون ان صوت الاغلبيه
وليس الاغلبيه المطلقه وبالتالي من يحصل
على اكبر عدد من الاصوات يصبح هو المتحدث
بغض النظر عن حصولها على اكثر من 50% في
هذه الحاله سيفوز
الديمقراطيطي الاختيار الثاني ان يكون ان
يتم اجراء اتفاق مع الديمقراطيين لتقديم
سواء مكارثي او غيره اي اي متحدث يعني
جمهوري ولكن بتقديم تنازلات كبيره
للديمقراطيين بحيث انهم اما يصوتون لصالحه
او يمتنعون عن التصويت بحيث يمكن تمرير
تصويته همم يعني يمكن تمرير كل الامرين
سيقدمان خدمات كبيره للانتصار كبير ضد
الديمقراطيين بالتالي هذه اللعبه خطيره
ولكن المشكله التي يعانيها ان هذه فئه في
الحقيقه هي تسبق ترامب هي موجوده قبل
ترامب ولكن ترامب يرى انه انهم هو من
صنعهم وبالتالي سيستمعون له وانه سيتم
انتخاب مكارتي في النهايه بالتالي يستطيع
ان يعلن انتصارا انه هو من مررت عين مكافي
ولكن يبدو ان هذا يعني
يبدو انه فشل في تحقيق التوقع طيب دكتور
بندر همم بشكل واضح نعم طيب ااه دكتور
بندر الحديث من قبل ترامب عن لعبه خطيره
تلعبها هذه المجموعه من النواب الجمهوريين
العشرين الذين همم يحولون دون انتخاب ابن
مارتي ماذا يقصد بهذه اللعبه الخطيره
وماذا يريدها هؤلاء
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بدون ترامب يمر
بازمه ازمه ثقه
الحزب الجمهوري هذه الفئه التي كما تفضل
ضيفهم انه قبل
ظهور ترامب لكن اعتقد الناس استفاده من
قوه ترامب مشاعبيه ترامب ومن وبالتالي
وترام يشعر ان لديه الاخضريه او لديه همم
القوه لاقناعها اولي المجموعه لكن اصبح
صوته ضعيفا مؤخرا وسط طلعت الرايت تؤكد
تراجعه الان ترامب لما يتحدث عن اللعبه
خطيره وهو يتحدث انه
وضعه همم اصبح يعني لا يريد ان يظهر بشكل
انه ضعيف ولم يستطيع ان يقنع هذه المجموعه
البسيطه في انتخابات واذا نجح وانا اعتقد
انه يصبح رئيسا
لكن اعتقد انها همم مرحله من التفاوض هنا
كما سمعنا انزلات كبيره قدم مسافي همم على
هذه اذا ارادوا ذلك الان تنازل مكارثي
وقدم ان هناك بامكان شخص واحد ان يطرح
عمليه التصويت همم قدم وضع ال 20 شخص هذا
هؤلاء في عده ليان همم تشريعيه لمراجعه
الثلاثيه
هل هناك اسماء بديله هل هناك بدلاء ما
كارتي ربما اا يراد تمريرهم ام انه
المساله كما قال الاستاذ احمد من هيستر
انه الرغبه هو ان اظهار حجم قوه دونالد
ترامب ربما هو يريد ان يستغل هذا الصراع
بان يحسنه هو في الحزب الجمهوري في
النهايه همم
انا لا ارى شخص بديل لمكان في عندما ترى
200 واتنين من الجمهوريين ينتخبون
مكارتي بينما عشرين فقط يعترض من الحزب
الجمودي على هذا الانتخاب لا اعتقد ان
هناك شخصيه مجمعه عليه الحزب الجمهوري
اكثر
في الوصول الى الكارثه الحزب الجمهوري
وتحذر
ماذا سيحصل ما هي السيناريوهات في حال
استمر فشل الجمهوريين وانقسامهم
على الانتخابات
التركيه المقبله هناك صعبه الديمقراطيه في
2024% مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي باتجاه همم
الجمهوريه
وقاموا بعمل اللجام تحقيقات مع
الديمقراطين والاداره الامريكيه الجمهوريه
مصر الحقيقيه جميله بان يقلبوا ميس الشيوخ
امريكي داخل
السلطه الديمقراطين يكون لهم او سيهدر
الديمقراطيه ان الجمهوريه الحزب مفكر حزب
مقسم لا لا يجدوا بها ان يكون في السلطه
سواء في الرياض سوف في الكونجرس وبالتالي
هذه اللعبه خطيره كما قال الرئيس الامريكي
دون ترامب وهو لا يريد ان تنتهي
بالفشلفي همم من عاد وص- بوصوله الى همم
متحدثا مجلس النواب
كما كنا استاذ احمد الحنطي فيه يسرا ترامب
الرئيس السابق اعتبرها يعني لعبه خطيره من
قبل الحزبه هذا الاعضاء هؤلاء النواب من
الحزب الجمهوري بينما الرئيس الحالي جو
بايدن همم الديمقراطي طبعا اعتبر ان ما
يحصل من فشل في انتخاب رئيس المجلس النواب
ويسيء للعمليه السياسيه والديمقراطيه
الامريكيه بشكل عام
لماذا لماذا يعني ما يحصل في مجلس النواب
يسيء الى الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
عاده تحسن في الغرف المغلقه تحسب بين
النواب او بين الشيوخ
يعني يجرون تصويطاتهم الداخليه ومنقاشاتهم
الداخليه بعيدا عن الاضواء ثم يخرجون كبها
موحده هذه الجبهه هي التي تقود البرنامج
التشريعي للحزب خلال الدوره القادمه لكن
عندما تخرج هذه كل هذه الصراعات وهذه
المشاكل وتصبح امام الجميع هذا يعني ان
الحزب غير قادر على فعل اي شيء وهذا هو
حزب الاغلبيه بالتالي امريكا غير قادر على
فعل اي شيء هذا ما يلامح له يعني من خلال
التصريحها ولكن الحقيقه انهم ديمقراطيين
يريدون تصويت الضوء بشكل
الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب لا تستطيع ان
تحضى بالاغلبيه فيما بينها يعني يعني هناك
مفارقه فما بالك انه فيما يتعلق بتشريع
القوانين الامريكيين وتنظيم حياتهم كذلك
بالضبط نحن يعني هم يريدون ان يظهروا
التناقض يعني
[موسيقى]
حصلت على يعني حصلت على مقعد المتحدث ب
216 صوت بخساره صوتين فقط من اصوات
الديمقراطيه رغم وجود معارضه كبيره من
الجناح الاكثر تطرفا في الحزب الديمقراطي
وتمكنت من تمرير مشاريع عدد كبير من
المشاريع يعني الضخمه وبعضها قد يكون مثير
للجدل من خلال المجلس الديمقراطيين يريدون
يقولون نحن
ناتي بغرض الحكم بغرض اداره الدوله بغرض
تحقيق منافع للناس بين الجمهوريه ان
يريدهم المعارض غير قادرين على فعله اي
شيء طيب دكتور بندر الدوشي ما هي توقعاته
كيف سيتم حسم هذا الجدل وهذا الصراع على
انتخاب كيف كانت رئيس المجلس النواب من
عدمه
انا اعود الى
تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي جو بالي بني ادم
مصري انا اعتقد ان الصحف الامريكيه اليوم
كانت تسخر من الديمقراطيه الامريكيه وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه صدقه على هذه ايضا في
اعتقاد
في ربما سيفوز فيه
[موسيقى]
كبيره جدا ولكن
سيكون الدفاع عن الهزيمه
هذه الفئه او الفصيل المتشدد همم ايضا همم
سيظهر
الديمقراطيين ان الحزب الجمهوري الصوره
افضل اظهرت الان ان حتى فوز ما كان في
يظهر ان الانسان ان هناك كثير الجمهوريه
وان العديد من التسريعات الضمان لن تبوك
وان الجمهوري اللي انت على الاجهزه ولكن
هناك اتفاق واضح على همم حصلت اداره
الرئيس الامريكي
والحدود وغيرها من الملفات التي المثير
الجدول التي ربما تقدمهم لاظهار الحسبه
الديمقراطي كانه يدير الدوله بشكل سيئه
عام 2024 نعم شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكم ضيفيه
الكريمين من جده الباحث العلاقات الدوليه
الدكتور بندر الدوشي ومنها استنى احمد
الحنطي الباحث في شان الامريكي